[Music]
we've got a good group tonight we're
gonna pick up where we left off last
evening and I want to start by opening
God's Word before we pray if you have a
Bible turn with me to Isaiah chapter 14
Isaiah 14 in Ezekiel 28 are both very
familiar texts that that describe what
happened to Satan before and during his
fall but we're going to go to Isaiah
chapter 14 verse 12 and for 12 through
14 it says how art thou fallen from
heaven o Lucifer son of the morning how
art thou cut down to the ground which
did weaken the nation's for thou hast
said in thine heart I will ascend into
heaven I will exalt my throne above the
stars of God I will sit also upon the
Mount of the congregation in the sides
of the north I will ascend above the
heights of the clouds I will be like the
Most High
Satan declared in his heart I will be
like the Most High I'm going to sit upon
his throne there's no way in a million
years that he really thought he was
gonna sit up there I'm he was he was
defeated Christ defeated him and threw
him down so what was the throne that he
was saying that he was going to take
it's what we spoke about the other night
it was the throne of men's hearts it
actually says I will sit also upon the
Mount of the congregation we know that
in Scripture Jerusalem here on the earth
was a physical shadow of the heavenly
Jerusalem and the scripture tells us
that New Jerusalem is the mother of us
all it's God's people yes it is a
literal City I'm not denying that but
just like Fresno if you say well Fresno
was destroyed well you can be talking
about the buildings or you can be
talking about the people the people are
what make the city a city without the
people it's meaningless just like a
church a church is a building but it's
more importantly it's the people that
make up that Church does that make sense
so Satan said I will sit upon the Mount
of the congregation and when you look in
revelation it actually describes New
Jerusalem and it gives the dimensions it
says that lies Foursquare and its height
is equal to each of its size so either
you have a cube or you have a pyramid my
personal opinion is I could see it very
well being a pyramid because the Bible
all through the Old Testament talks
about the mountain of the Lord and it
equates that with this people and if you
ask any child over three years old to
draw a mountain they're gonna draw a
pyramid very simple anyway that that is
where Lucifer said he would take
possession he would sit upon that throne
so I want us to keep that in mind as we
as we go through tonight's messages so
let's open with the word of Prayer
father in heaven we thank you for your
son the Lord Jesus Christ and father
that word Lord means the sovereign
Father we claim and we thank you for
your promise that at the name of Jesus
Christ every knee shall bow and every
tongue shall confess both in heaven and
on earth we ask that you send holy
angels that excel in strength tonight
fill this house with thy presence bind
and cast out all the powers of darkness
that would seek to interfere with your
work and ministry in our lives and
father most of all caused us to see your
glory and to hear thy voice alone in
Jesus name we ask in Him we believe and
thank you
amen I'm gonna open and reread something
we looked at last night this comes from
one of the testimonies that sister white
gave to us she said as we near the close
of time there will be greater and still
greater external external outward parade
of heathen power what's the difference
between a group of people that are just
walking silently down the road and a
parade a parade seeks to draw attention
to itself this statement tells us that
demonic entities are going to be seeking
recognition by mankind and heathen
deities will manifest their signal power
and exhibit themselves before the cities
of the world and this delineation has
already begun to be fulfilled and we
spoke about that last night when I first
read this I thought this is talking
about fallen angels that we will see
with our eyes I thought I mean is this
taking place because Ellen White's
this has already begun to be fulfilled
and then I kept reading all need wisdom
carefully to search out the mystery of
iniquity that figures so largely in the
winding up of this Earth's history and I
started seeing something that is so
important for us to know two mysteries
the mystery of godliness which first
Timothy 3:16 tells us that is God
manifest in the flesh and then the
second mystery is the mystery of
iniquity if you want to know what the
mystery of iniquity is all you have to
do is know what the mystery of godliness
is God manifests in the flesh the
mystery of iniquity is Satan and his
fallen angels manifest in the flesh let
no man deceive you by any means for that
day of Christ's return shall not come
except there come an apostasy first and
that man of sin be unveiled as the son
of perdition who opposeth and exalteth
himself above all that is called God or
that is worshipped so that he as God
sitteth in the temple of God showing
himself that He is God Christ said
something in the Gospels he said why do
you call me Lord Lord but yet don't do
the things that I say and and he
actually said something very similar
through the Apostle Paul he said don't
you realize that to whom you yield
yourself as a servant to obey that's
whose servants you are I want you to
remember that because if Christ reigns
within a man or a woman's heart do you
know that scientists now have seen
what Darwin never even thought was
possible they have looked inside of the
human cell and they have seen it is more
complex and more active than an entire
city one cell one human cell there are
these tiny little microbes and all these
little things that are obeying the
instructions that are given to them by
the DNA that DNA is actually the
instructions or the book of life
according to what scientists are saying
so that means that every organ of our
body every cell of our body is supposed
to be under the authority and the reign
of the Lord Jesus Christ
that's how jesus healed the sick when
men surrendered their heart to him he
took the driver's seat and he commanded
every organ of their body every gland
every nerve and every cell obey bring
yourself into submission and he causes
that to happen today just as he did
2,000 years ago but when sin is
introduced it's like a virus in a
computer it corrupts the perfect code of
life that God gave to us in his word
that's why Christ says if you will abide
in me the Word of God and it's my words
which are spirit and life abide in you
you can ask what you will and it will be
done for you Satan said I want to take
that throne I want to be the one that
issues the commands the Apostle Paul
tells us know ye not that you are the
temple of God and that the Spirit of God
dwells in you if any man defiles the
temple of God him shall God destroy for
our God is a consuming
fire now I want to I want to show you
just a little bit of where spiritualism
is today and how we are seeing evil
spirits manifest physically externally
this was a picture of me and the first
Grandmaster I trained under and you can
tell when you look in my eyes that it
was I was a different person I don't
even like looking at the pictures
anymore of what I was like back then
even my family pictures it's like I told
my wife I said I want to just take them
down I walk by and it's not even the
same person because of what I had
allowed into my life through sin and
through participation in these dark arts
I want to tell a story real quickly the
last Grandmaster I trained under I
trained under - over the 25 years that I
was active in the martial arts and
Eastern mysticism the last Grandmaster I
trained under he was a tenth dawn or
tenth degree in two systems of kung fu
of Chinese martial arts he was also a
master instructor in what's called
medical ki gong or acupuncture
acupressure laying on hands and healing
people he could put his hands on you and
he could tell you had a disease and what
it was and it wasn't physical the
spirits would speak to him it had
nothing to do with you really being able
to put your hands on there you just put
your hands there sometimes somebody
would just walk in the room and you knew
what was wrong with them and you didn't
know how you knew but the devil would
tell you what's because of your training
and pride would grow and you would
become more sure of your ability but I
went to train with this man one night
and it was or one day one weekend and he
taught only black belts the
second Grand Master I trained under you
had to be a black belt didn't matter
what style it was in so he was training
all of us black belts and then he would
depend on us to take what we had learned
from him to teach our students
well we trained all day long everybody
was exhausted and he asked us he said
why don't we you know hang around here
we can get some food we were training at
his home where his studio is training
hall was and so we all were excited
about the fact that you know he invited
us to stay because that means you're
going to get little special things that
he doesn't normally disclose to other
people and so we sat and we ate and we
talked and and turned the television on
and just hung out for a while and it got
later and later and I started watching
the other black belts there and they
were getting they were getting really
tired and then the grandmaster started
talking about conspiracy theories like
the Illuminati and Freemasons and all
anything out there and I know a lot of
its true but none of these guys were
interested and you could see them they
were I mean they were doing everything
they could to stay awake
and you didn't want to fall asleep
because if the Grandmaster is talking
and you fall asleep on him you know
you're not gonna be promoted that could
put you back at least a year maybe two
years before you're even up for
promotion so everyone is fighting to
keep their eyes open and when he started
talking about conspiracy theories I woke
up I mean I was just like okay I'm
interested in this and sometime after
12:00 or 1:00 o'clock that night late
when everyone was really exhausted he
changed his line of thought in an
instant he's talking about all these
different things and then all of a
sudden he looked at us and he said you
know I teach you all how to tap into
this power that we call Chi energy
he said but let me tell you if you want
to see this energy demonstrated he said
the easiest place to see this power
demonstrated is look at Jimi Hendrix
look at Eric Clapton look at a lot of
the movie stars that are out there he
said they are using the same power that
we use in the martial arts only they use
it for a different reason and when he
said that it was like a red flag went up
in my mind because I knew I mean I was
still going to church every week and and
you know I would still quote a Christian
but I knew Jimi Hendrix was not a
god-fearing man I knew Eric Clapton was
not a god-fearing man I knew some of the
Hollywood stars he talked about were not
church-going god-fearing Bible believing
Christians and he said they were using
the same power that we were but they
were using it to hypnotize to enthrall
their audiences one day I was there at
the studio alone with him and he he was
teaching me and one of the black belts
came running in and he had a huge piece
of artwork that was wrapped up in brown
paper and he said see Joe Grand Master
he said it's finished it's finished and
the instructor he nodded to him you and
dismissing him and he unwrapped the
paper and there was this beautiful
Chinese calligraphy on the on the paper
on the parchment and he had hired a
Chinese artist to paint this calligraphy
and he looked at it and I could tell he
was very proud of it and I looked at it
it was beautiful but I had no idea what
it said and he looked at me knowing what
I was thinking and I asked him I said
see Joe what does it mean and he looked
at the floor on
forget this and then he looked back up
in my eyes and he said the easiest
translation in English is it's the devil
that's in the details I should have run
I'm at should have run but you know what
I did because I'd been training in these
arts for over 20 years I made excuses
well that may mean that to him but I
know it you know it doesn't mean that to
me and people do the same thing when
they talk to me about yoga they say well
I know they're praying to Hindu gods but
I'm praying to Jesus when I do yoga and
I'm like you know you can't what why are
you in an idols temple you know why even
go there he told me it's the devil
that's in the details and that was such
an important truth in those arts that we
trained in that he paid a lot of money
to have this Chinese artist paint that
now I want to show you what sister White
was talking about this is Robin Williams
he passed away a few years ago I hate
what the enemy did to him because
there's numerous interviews that they
have done with him on different
magazines different television shows and
he was he was a tormented man and he
knew why he was tormented he knew what
it was he wound up committing suicide
because of what these evil spirits did
to him listen to what he said in this
interview with Us Weekly he said yeah
literally it's like possession all of
the sudden you're in and because it's in
front of a live audience
you just get this energy that it just
starts going but there's also that thing
it is possession in the old days you'd
be burned for it but there's something
empowering about it I mean it
it's a place where you are totally it's
it's like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde where
you really can become this other force
maybe that's why I don't need to play
evil characters in movies because
sometimes on stage you can cross that
line and still come back he was talking
about when he was a live comedian he he
was talking about comedy before he
became an actor he said it's possession
you get up and you start talking and he
said something else comes in and all of
a sudden you're a completely different
person you all know who this is Oprah
Winfrey listen to what she said she said
I asked God for grace and I want to ask
you a question what does the word grace
mean in Greek what's the original
unmerited favor did you know that's the
second definition when you look it up in
Strong's I did not know that - a few
years ago and I looked it up one day do
you know what the first definition is
the divine influence upon the heart and
it's reflection as seen in the life it's
the Spirit of God now with that in mind
listen to what she says I asked God for
grace and the power of the spirits
plural calling on you calling on you I
really believe I can call her
this spirit up her and so many others
Oprah Winfrey calls these her go there
moments spiritual episodes of divine
guidance that far transcend the chatty
exchanges with her studio audiences
Winfrey says she has come to know each
of them personally and she
calls them in at will to guide her in
her work
that's from Time magazine that I mean
that's frightening you want to know how
she got where she is that's how and I
have probably more than a hundred
different testimonies from different
people and we're only going to show you
just a few do you all recognize this man
Michael Landon Little House on the
Prairie I grew up and we were allowed to
watch Walt Disney one day a week you
know came on Sunday evenings for an hour
and we could watch the Little House on
the Prairie and sometimes Andy Griffith
you know those who are what you call
safe right there family friendly people
will say well they're Christian listen
to what Michael Landon said he said I
felt my father's presence with me this
is after his father had died I felt my
father's presence with me enlightening
my memories helping me to commit to
paper the feelings I had I really heard
my father speaking to me from the other
dimension filling my mind with just the
right words the story came so fast and
was so right in three days the script
was complete his daughter actually wrote
a whole book on the life of her father
and she said there was often times when
they were doing a little house on the
prairie or touched by an angel
there was another one of those films
that he did I don't remember the name of
it it was a television series and she
said they would be struggling to get the
script and he would take a piece of
paper or a pad of paper go into his
bedroom and lock the door and he would
come out the next morning with the
entire script wrote complete that's not
possible I've done one script in my life
and it was unbelievably a long hard haul
to
put down those thoughts in the order
they're supposed to be in he did it in
one night and he did it numerous times
but he would go in there and he would
speak with spirits and they would give
him the story I'm gonna skip yes I'm
gonna skip this one I will tell you I'm
hoping that I'll be able to show it
later this week it's an interview from
with Denzel Washington and the interview
was done on 60 minutes he said the exact
same thing the interviewer was asking
them how did you play this part so well
in this this film and Denzel said I
could never do that there's no way in
the world I could ever make a conscious
decision to act that part and he asked
him he said well how did you do that
this was a powerful scene he said well
he said I went into the room and got
down on my knees and I asked the spirits
to come in he said when I got up
it wasn't me anymore and you can look
that up online Revelation chapter 18
says after these things I saw another
angel come down from heaven having great
power and the earth was lightened with
his glory and he cried mightily with a
strong voice that means a loud cry
saying Babylon the Great is fallen is
fallen for she has become the habitation
of devils there's two cities in
scripture there's Jerusalem and there's
Babylon yes they are literal cities but
more importantly they are symbolic of
God's people and Satan's people Babylon
has fallen and become the habitation of
devils and the hold or stronghold of
every foul spirit and a cage of every
unclean and hateful bird
and I heard another voice from heaven
saying come out of her my people that
she be not partakers of her sins and
that you receive not of her plagues for
her sins have reached unto heaven and
God hath remembered her iniquities
before our Savior returns every man
woman or child on this earth will be
possessed 100% they will either be
filled with the Spirit of the Living God
or they will be the dwelling place of
demons now I grew up as a Christian as a
Seventh day Adventist Christian and I
kind of thought demon possession was you
know somebody's cutting himself and
they've got you know tattoos all over
their face and they're throwing up and
they're you know acting crazy and then I
read the story about Judas that Ellen
White wrote and she said Judas was
possessed with a demon of selfishness
selfishness that's what caused him to
lose his life and she said Christ did
everything he could to keep Judas close
to him to win his heart if Judas had
surrendered Christ would have commanded
that evil spirit to leave he would have
evicted him but Judas wouldn't yield and
because of that that spirit became
stronger and he brought other spirits in
something to make a note of it says here
about Babylon her sins have reached unto
heaven and God has remembered her
iniquities if you look up the the
promise of the New Covenant in Jeremiah
31 in Hebrews 8 and Hebrews 10 it tells
us this is the covenant I will make with
the house of Israel that means those
that have faith he said I will forgive
your sins in the nick wood
and I will remember them no more
Babylon their sins are remembered
because they have no faith they have no
faith but Israel it says in the Old
Testament you will search for your
iniquities and they won't be found amen
and you know when that happened 2,000
years ago the days in which we live are
eventful and full of peril the signs of
the coming of the end are thickening all
around us and events to come to pass
that will be of a more terrible
character than any the world has yet
witnessed for when they shall say peace
and safety then sudden destruction will
come upon them as a woman with child and
they shall not escape we are to realize
that the judgments of God are about to
fall we're living in this time now it's
not five years from now it's not it's
now the judgments of God are about to
fall upon the earth solemn events before
us are yet to transpire I want you to
pay attention to this they are yet to
transpire look at the next thing she
says trumpet after trumpet is to be
sounded this is not controversy I
encourage you to do the research on your
own there's other places where Ellen
White says the seven trumpets they did
they were not fulfilled a hundred and
fifty two hundred three hundred years
ago they are yet to sound when you look
at the Old Testament the plan the way of
God's working in the Old Testament he
had certain special days on the cow
under that marked events he had Passover
in the spring you had firstfruits which
was three days after then you had
Pentecost and then you had the summer
and then you had trumpets Day of
Atonement Tabernacles if you look at Day
of Atonement we a Seventh day Adventists
we would call that close of probation
because on that day every case was
decided if you were a member of Israel
right before the day of atonement
happened 10 days prior to it God
commanded them to blow trumpets to warn
the people and tell them to get ready
when you look in Revelation at the
trumpets almost every one of the
trumpets it says and men repented not
that means they still had opportunity to
repent God sends these trumpet judgments
with mercy because he's driving to win
men's hearts before the close of
probation before that final day of
decision is ended
she says trumpet after trumpet is to be
sounded vial after vial poured out one
after another upon the inhabitants of
the earth and we should most earnestly
present before the people the warning
that the Lord has commissioned us to
give Paul tells us in second
Thessalonians remember ye not that when
I was yet with you I told you these
things but now you know he that
withholdeth so that he might be unveiled
in his time for the mystery of iniquity
doth already work I don't want to spend
a lot of time on this because we've
discussed this and some other messages
but our current Bishop of Rome
Pope Francis you can do the research on
your own his sister as well as many of
the Cardinals and bishops when Pope
Francis was elected to take that
position he also went into a room and
closed the door alone and they said that
when he came out of the room he was a
completely different man his sister's
own words when she wrote about him
she said I no longer know the man that
is the Pope she said you know I love him
he's my brother she said but he's not
the one that went into that room she
said he was never charismatic and now
he's kissing babies and hugging people
and and playing contemporary Christian
rock music and and smiling and laughing
and hugging she said he never would have
done that even the other bishops there
in the Catholic Church said a change
happened and it happened in that short
time he went into that room alone and
closed that door is it possible that
something went in to him for this last
time the message of Christ's
righteousness is to sound from one end
of the earth to the other to prepare the
way of our Lord this is the glory of God
which closes the work of the third angel
Christ's righteousness the word
righteousness we looked at up last night
and it literally means holiness purity
innocence victory and perfect
righteousness perfection several have
written to me inquiring if the message
of justification by faith is the third
angel's message they were struggling
because in many minds the third angel's
message was we've got to warn the world
about Babylon we've got to warn the
world about the mark of the beast and
about who
Pope is and that's true but it doesn't
stop on just a physical description what
God was wanting to reveal to the world
was the righteousness that we can have
today by faith in his promises by we can
have victory today he says that in
Hebrews chapter three and four he says
it in 2nd Corinthians chapter 6 verse 2
he says today is the day of your
salvation not next week not 10 years
from now today when those two men the
the Demoniacs of Ghidorah they came
running down the beach at Jesus and
Ellen White says that when they were
running toward him the men that were in
the back seat of that vehicle their
their body the men that owned that body
they had been gagged and tied up and
they were in the back seat demons
legions of fallen angels had taken
possession of these men and they saw
Jesus and they were like he can set us
free and they ran towards him in hope
for freedom and it says that when they
opened their mouth to ask for help
the demons spoke through them rather
than allowing them to speak the demons
did and Jesus saw what was happening and
I want to tell you something do you know
those men asked Jesus they said we want
to go with you Jesus did not tell them
you need to go home and spend the next
12 months on Bible studies then come
back and talk to me and we can ordain
you and then you can go out and start
sharing the gospel do you know what
Jesus said go now and tell what great
things God has done for you when he set
them free it was not an evolutionary
process the only reason it takes
time for perfection of character is
because of the lack of our faith I know
some men that have struggled with
cigarettes for forty years and they
would surrender to Christ they would
fight for one night on their knees and
they'd get up the next morning and they
never touched another cigarette one
night and I know other people that have
spent 10 years battling and still
haven't got the victory is the
difference because Christ's power is
less in one person's life or is it a
matter of faith believing that God will
do what he says amen it's faith when he
told that man at the Pool of Bethesda
take up your bed and walk he didn't put
him on a rehabilitation program I'm a
firm believer in the health message I
drink carrot juice every day I love to
eat healthy but that's not the miracle
of healing it's part of it but God says
I speak righteousness just like that man
at the Pool of Bethesda had been laying
there he spoke the word and the man
believed it
remember that several have written to me
inquiring if the message of
justification by faith is the third
angel's message and I have answered it
is the third angel's message in Verity
for the Prophet declares after these
things I saw another angel come down
from heaven having great power and the
earth was lightened with his glory I
want I want to show you something they
were asking is justification by faith is
that the third angel's message when you
look up the word justification and I'm
going to show this over and over again
because it's that important it means to
declare and render innocent just
clean holy righteous pure and perfect
that's what justification is that thief
on the cross I can't tell you how many
Christians have written to me and said
well you're giving me this list of
things that I have to do what about that
thief on the cross I'm not throwing out
God's law but I'm encouraging us let's
not put the cart in front of the horse
Jesus came to set us free so that we
could live holy and righteous lives
because as long as you're in bondage to
the old man you're gonna work really
hard and still never make it you'll
never achieve what you want that's what
Nicodemus was battling with and Jesus
said you have to be born again it's not
you just haven't and something else to
add to your list of do's and dont's you
have got to be begotten over again by
the Spirit of the Living God and once
your insides are changed the outside
will delight to obey me in Romans
chapter 8 Paul tells us the carnal mind
is enmity against God it's not subject
to the law of God and neither indeed can
it be when we have people that will call
our house and they're like I can't get
my husband to stop watching ready to our
movies I can't get my my son or my
grandson to quit listening to rock and
roll music and you know what can I do
and I'm like the first thing you've got
to ask is have they been born again have
they surrendered their lives to Christ
because if they have not done that and
all you're trying to do is fix the
externals that's what the Pharisees did
they wash the outside of the tombs and
inside it was full of dead men's bones
that child or that husband or that wife
or your brother or sister or mother or
father if they if you go to them and say
you've got to stop eating pork or you've
got to start going to church on Saturday
and they haven't been born again you
know what they're thinking look I'm
already trying to do these nine and
you're just giving me one more that I
can't do I don't need more things to do
I'm not doing well on the ones of God
the carnal mind is not subject to the
law of God it can't be that's why the
Bible says let this mind be in us which
was in Christ Jesus there has to be a
change inside so that the outside will
blossom and produce the fruits of
righteousness listen to what the servant
of the Lord says as yet we certainly
have not seen the light that answers to
this description God has light for his
people and all who will accept it will
see the sinfulness of remaining in a
lukewarm condition they will heed the
counsel of the true witness when he says
be zealous therefore and repent behold
I'm standing at the door of your heart
knocking and If any man will hear my
voice my word and open the door I will
come into you and I will sup with you
and you with me do you know what that
sup means it means he'll have dinner
with you
what does he feed us the bread of life
he said that's what John 6 was all about
eat my words make them part of your life
Satan is doing the exact same thing he
told Eve at the at the tree of knowledge
of good and evil if you will just eat
of what I'm offering you then you'll be
like God knowing good and evil he wanted
them to partake of his words and his
spirit rather than the Spirit of the
Living God
serpents whisper and the shadow of doubt
the Serpent's whisper this takes us back
all the way to the very beginning and
tomorrow evening and tonight but
tomorrow evening especially we're gonna
bring together again these these pieces
of the puzzle and we're going to show
how this relates to spiritual formation
in the emerging church we did some of
that last night but tomorrow night
especially but I want you to listen to
what we're told
what exactly is spiritual formation I
have many people that will talk to me
they'll they'll meet at a conference or
something and there's this I don't even
know what it is what is spiritual
formation they know people say it's bad
but they don't know what it is and I
have to admit I knew it was bad I knew
that you had this liberal theology that
was attached to it but I wondered I was
like what does that mean why does it
have that name spiritual formation
here's a couple of colleges and
universities that are heavy promoters of
this I don't want to name names but you
can read those there for yourself it's
in it's in every denomination not just
ours it's everywhere when you see what
the Apostle Paul says it makes this
clear he says my little children of whom
I travail in birth again until Christ be
formed in you for we brethren just as
Isaac was are the children of promise
but as then he which was born after or
begotten by the flesh persecuted him
that was borne by the spirit even so it
is now spiritual formation is forming a
man or woman into the image of God
do you remember what Satan said to Eve
if you will obey if you'll listen to my
words and eat of my words you will be
like gods
how much more like God could you be they
were already made in His image
Adam luke says was the son of God my
creation you can't be any more like God
than to be his son or daughter but Satan
said you're not really you're not really
like God taste and see try what I'm
offering you and then you'll be like God
the first sin that caused the fall of
the entire human race was doubting who
they were as sons and daughters of the
Living God do you know what the first
temptation that Christ faced in the
wilderness was the exact same thing
Satan came to him and Ellen White says
it's when Satan said if that then Christ
recognized who he was Satan appeared as
an angel of light Christ did not
recognize him until Satan started
speaking and Satan told Christ if thou
be the Son of God command this stone to
be made bread when he said if Christ
recognized this is him and he Amen
that's right when he came up out of the
River Jordan after being baptized his
father had declared from heaven thou art
my beloved son in DMI well-pleased
christ had to walk by faith now I want
to encourage you with something and I
also want to challenge you do you know
what it says in first John
it says now are you the sons of God and
it does not yet appear what we shall be
like but we know that when he appears we
will be like him for we shall see him as
he is we're not waiting for some day to
become children of God and the word sons
in Greek means children begotten so it
means sons and daughters I'm not trying
to pervert Scripture but I mean we can
take that and know that we're on safe
ground men and women mankind but it says
now now we are the children of God and
then look what it says in John one born
not of blood nor of the will of the
flesh nor of the will or power of man
but of God I cannot tell you how many
Christians are striving with all their
might to achieve something that's
impossible for man to do you have to
believe it and then it becomes yours
that's called fighting the fight of
faith you have to believe God's promised
and appropriated as your own and when
you take hold of that promise and you
say it's yay and all men in Christ Jesus
I am his he is mine that promise is mine
when you do that and you speak faith
Ellen White says you will have faith and
Hebrews 11 says faith is the very
substance of the things you have been
given confidence and assurance of amen
to whom god would make known what is the
riches the abundance of the glory of
this mystery remember we talked about
those two mysteries the mystery of
godliness and the mystery of iniquity
Paul
talking about the mystery of godliness
here he says to us to whom god would
make known what is the abundance of the
glory of this mystery among the gentiles
even that mystery which hath been hid
from ages and from generations but now
is made manifest to his saints today if
you will but hear my voice which is
Christ in you the hope of glory every
promise in Christ Jesus is yay and in
him amen
he says if you'll only believe and I can
remember when I was battling to get free
I told the Lord one day it was like I
saw it it says whosoever believes shall
be saved and the word saved does not
mean you have a free ticket to get into
heaven the word saved in Greek in Hebrew
means rescued delivered set free healed
and made whole and I looked that day
because I was crying out to God for
freedom I mean the martial arts and
Eastern mysticism was just up that was
just a tiny little part of the the sins
I had been in bondage to going through
that divorce with my wife and I had
committed adultery and I had I had
baggage from all the way back when I was
a child and I was begging God I didn't
need freedom
I need salvation and God told me he said
you don't even know what the word saved
means he said look it up and I looked it
up and it said that freedom rescue
deliverance healing and to make you
whole and I said God there's five
definitions which one is right and you
know what he told me which one do you
need today
where are you do you need physical
healing and you know what when he spoke
that to me I started that day I opened
up the Gospels I said I'm not leaving
the Gospels
I got a notepad out and I just started
reading the Gospels and I made am note
every single time I saw a captive set
free
I saw someone healed I saw someone
forgiving
I saw a prostitute forgiving and I was
like God you know I committed adultery
but I've never charged somebody for it
and God was like I know I can handle you
don't have a sin that's bigger than me
and I made a note of every single time
Christ healed and set someone free and
every time it was based on one thing did
they believe what God had already
promised to do and I took I told the
Lord I said I'm there in the house by
myself my wife is a schoolteacher my
children are going to school and I
looked up because I was so desperate I
said how do I believe I can't even make
myself believe faith cometh by hearing
and hearing by the word and the Lord
Jesus Christ told me in Romans chapter
10 verse 17 he said Erik quit reading my
words silently in your head start
reading it out loud and I'll never
forget the man that first encouraged me
to do that he was an older man of God I
don't even know what church he went to
but I'd called him on the phone because
I desperately needed help and he asked
me that question
he said Erik when you read God's Word do
you read it in your head or do you read
it out loud I said in my head he said
when you pray do you pray only in your
head or do you pray out loud I sit in my
head and then he asked me a question
I'll never forget he said why and I said
I don't want the devil to hear me and
you know what he said he said do you
think the devil stronger than the one
you're praying to and I went oh wow that
was the last time I worried about the
devil hearing my prayers
if I don't want the devil to hear what
I'm saying you know what I do I say Lord
Jesus Christ I want this prayer between
to be between me and you and my father
and heaven and that's it I ask you in
your name and Jesus said if you ask
anything in my name I will do it we
don't fear the devil doesn't mean we
have to be arrogant and foolish but
greater is He that is in us than he that
is in this world and as I started
reading his promises out loud faith grew
like I have met I never could have
imagined how much the faith grew and I
still battle I still have days where I
come under attack and my wife I'll call
her and when I'm having a bad day the
Lord will have her on top of the
mountain and she'll say let me pray with
you Eric and she'll speak those promises
out loud and she'll say don't speak the
doubt speak faith in his word and Ellen
White said the same thing she said don't
talk about what the devil's done to you
talk about the promises of your your
Savior and your mighty God amen let's uh
let's close with the word of Prayer
father in heaven we thank you that you
are not a man that you should lie nor
the son of man that you should change
your mind your word has gone forth and
it shall not return unto you void father
you have spoken and you will make it
good father you have told us through
faith and patience we inherit the
promises and father we are gonna do like
Jacob did we are going to grab hold on
your son and say I will not let thee go
except thou bless me not because we are
worthy but because he is worthy and
because you are faithful and cannot lie
father we pray for every family and
individual that is represented here
tonight father let us not only discern
the
evil but most importantly let us see and
know your power in our lives
[Music]